what do you mean show us now why seven  is a happy number so let's start with  the number seven so let's square seven  because all numbers like to be squared  I'm sure that's the root of all  happiness so seven squared gives us 49  so I'm going to take each of those  digits and square those so 4 squared I'm  going to add them together so I get 16  plus 81 equals ninety seven so let's  square each of those 81 plus 49 right  gives me 130 let's try again one squared  plus three squared plus zero squared  gives me ten one more iteration I think  will be there one squared plus zero  squared equals one this makes my number  seven a happy number it's happy because  it ends up with one which is one is your  first natural number it's the number all  numbers are based upon if it's different  you won't get one that means this number  will be a sad number it's not  particularly important it's just fun  you